[Music]
what is up everybody it's animac here
for anime uproar and welcome to another
installment of our weekly anime newscast
where you can catch up on all the latest
anime and manga news of the past week
all the links are in the description and
recommendations for next week go in the
comments episode 31 of my hero Academia
a this past weekend wrapping up the
stain Arc and last week we received the
news that this upcoming episode episode
32 is actually going to be a new anime
Original Episode and it's going to be
focusing on tuyu asui and her internship
experience this episode is going to be a
side story that does not appear in the
manga and it is also going to introduce
some new characters that do not appear
in the manga so as someone who reads the
manga I do find this very interesting in
general myo Academia theim follows the
manga quite closely so I'm looking
forward to seeing these new characters
for the first time let me know down in
the comments if you're excited for this
if you're a tuyu fanboy or if you think
this is just going to be pointless
filler and you're not that happy about
it in anime uproar news we are now
approaching that crazy 50,000
subscribers Mark I mean I remember just
a few months ago we hit 10,000 and I
thought that was crazy so this is just
an insane accomplishment we are so
thrilled both Goen and and so
appreciative to all of you for
supporting us and we want to let you
know right now that we're going to be
planning some crazy party events to
celebrate 50k subscribers whenever we do
reach that amazing Mark what we're going
to be doing is we're going to be having
a special episode of our Rand Cafe
podcast dedicated to that to celebrating
50k having a Q&A with you guys we do
this podcast the Rand Cafe podcast every
Thursday at 5:00 p.m. Eastern Standard
Time live on this channel so be sure to
drop by you can check chat with us live
while we discuss various anime topics
also when we reach that 50k Mark we're
going to be hosting an all day Discord
party on our anime opo Discord server
Link in the description we've already
done one of these in the past and it was
a lot of fun we're going to be chatting
in voice chat together watching anime
together playing some party games it's
always a lot of fun so be sure to check
out our Discord server and finally when
we reach 50k we're going to be having
some twitch parties as well where we're
going to play some online party games
together with you guys to celebrate just
hang out have a good time so if you
don't follow us on Twitch you can check
us out
twitch.tv/ animeuproar last week we
learned that Sony Pictures bought a
majority share of Funimation now if you
look at the FUNimation website they are
claiming that nothing is going to change
the time they take to release their
anime is not going to change their
relationship with Crunchyroll is not
going to change their subscription
service is not going to change however
is it really possible for a huge company
like Sony to buy FUNimation and for
nothing to change what do you guys think
personally I have to admit I am not that
familiar with how Corporate Acquisitions
work but if you do know something about
this and if you think that this will
make some important changes to
FUNimation be sure to let me know in the
comments just recently the newest
chapter of the attack on Titan manga
chapter 96 came out we already uploaded
a review of it on our Channel if you
want to check that out I will leave the
link in the description but one thing
that I did not know until I came across
a Crunchyroll article
is that there was a whole bunch of
references to Game of Thrones in the
latest Attack on Titan chapter now isama
the attack on Titan mangaa has already
in the past based some of the Mindless
Titans on people that he knows and
fictional characters as well however I
did not notice that all of these
mindless Titans were actually a
reference to Game of Throne characters
so kudos to this Crunchyroll article for
figuring this out and pointing it out
I'm a big fan of both Game of Thrones
and Attack on Titan although of course I
am a bigger fan of Attack on Titan but I
enjoy Game of Thrones as well so I
thought this was pretty awesome also if
you're a fan of Attack on Titan just a
few days ago we uploaded a new Attack on
Titan video where we tried to untangle
three of the biggest mysteries in the
attack on Titan manga so be sure to
check that out a little while ago we
learned that the Stein gate zero visual
novel is going to be getting an anime
adaptation in 2018 and this could
potentially be good news for Stein's
gate fans or the adaptation could suck I
don't know I'm kind of in the Middle
with this one let me know what you think
about this adaptation I love the
original series but then the film that
came out afterwards wasn't as good so
I'm a bit concerned but looking forward
to it either way just today gigguk
uploaded what I thought was a really
timely and important video about Netflix
and Anime strike and about some of the
big problems in their streaming services
when it comes to the anime Community if
you're one of those people has been
really pissed lately about these
services and how they bring their anime
content to Their audience I definitely
recommend checking out this video Guk
offers a really good analysis of the
issue and then he goes on to provide
some really excellent advice on how to
potentially resolve it so yeah
definitely check it out Link in the
description and my favorite AMV for this
week is Anime Recon top 10 new anime
with cool SL badass male lead these top
10 lists that Recon makes have been
doing really well on his channel they've
been help helping him grow and it's
because they are a really high quality
product he combines top 10 lists with
amvs so instead of talking about the
anime he actually makes an AMV with all
the anime in it he always picks some
really good music and he does a great
job editing so like I said I always
enjoy these videos and I definitely
recommend checking out this one Link in
the description although Recon I will
say that your number one pick is going
to generate some controversy for obvious
reasons and that is it for this week
guys if you enjoy these videos be sure
to like And subscribe and until next
time see you Space
[Music]
[Applause]
Cowboys